il ya des tabous de plaisir pays mais il
ya une nouvelle dimension où moi je suis
toujours dans la musique contemporaine
donc maintenant on essaye de faire le
pont entre cette musique traditions et
les aigus quand un poème c'est moi le
pont l'expérience et la hausse est
fantastique j'apprends plein de plein de
choses et c'est un sport que je crois
que avec une diversité par ace et c'est
vraiment fantastique
on a joué deux matchs bellay à la maison
gibert à sept maris c'est un truc qu'on
va retenir toute notre vie et c'est
impressionnant de voir des anciens
toujours là et toujours à partager a
toujours donné aux jeunes et mais ça
c'est un truc sans regarder dont il se
sent a pas oubliés nous partageons
[Musique]
beaucoup de cultures bourg de percussion
on n'est pas les même nationalité
ici en tout cas on a fait notre vie mais
essayez c'est la percussion on navigue
vraiment ils sont imprégnés de dents
ils sont il aime beaucoup et connaissent
pas mal de morceaux
et puis je pense qu'il ya des personnes
âgées qui donnent leur savoir et je
pense que ça c'était très bon